Matt ripe has officially broken the
internet with millions of social media
followers and a Ticketmaster crashing
Comedy Tour people see him now and
assume oh he's easy on the eyes this
must have been so easy well in reality
it took him years to get to where he is
today and this video is going to share
all the tea on his social media stardom
hated him and abdomen
now we're talking about internet Fame so
there's gonna be some haters but as the
song goes you ain't got no haters you
ain't popping popping what a lot of
people don't know is that Rife ain't new
to this he grew to this all of this Fame
was built without any help from the
comedy industry everything Matt has was
built by his fans starting with his
first comedy special funded by his fans
foreign
[Music]